[Music]
hi everyone its Charlie this is gonna be
my Avengers 5 top 10 WTF questions what
is going on with the next Avengers film
there were a lot of big problems at the
end of Avengers endgame that none of the
characters really addressed that they'll
have to deal with in those future movies
so if you're brand new to the channel be
sure to subscribe to get all the Marvel
Easter Egg videos we're gonna learn
about Marvel phase 4 this summer at
Comic Con after spider-man far from home
comes out we're also doing an IMAX
ticket giveaway for that too
all you have to do to enter is be a
subscriber and leave an Avengers comment
on the video obviously careful for
spoilers for Avengers in game but
starting with number 10 when will they
actually release Avengers 5 is it gonna
be 3 years is gonna be 4 years typically
every Marvel phase of movies phase 1
phase 2 and phase 3 were capped at the
end with an Avengers team-up before you
start a new phase the last two cycles
have been Avengers movies every three
years not including Avengers end game
because that was back-to-back with
infinity war the only exception to that
was the very first Avengers movie it
took four years after the first Iron Man
film to get to that just because they
had so many characters to introduce for
the first time in so many concepts to
deal with the Avengers as a brand is so
important to Disney they will always do
Avengers films regardless of who the
roster is if you look at the Disney Park
situation they spent so much money
developing their parks like Star Wars
land they're making a marvel land in the
next couple of years and look at the
symbol that they're using to tease it
it's not a Marvel logo it's the Avengers
logo because it's much more specific in
evocative of the Avengers characters
right now I wouldn't be surprised if
they wait for years to get to that next
Avengers film because there are so many
new characters that are trying to
introduce during Marvel phase four and
they have those Avengers spin-off TV
shows to sort of fill in the gaps so
they're not rushing to get four or five
films out a year number nine what
happened to the fabric of the universe
now that Thanos destroyed our version of
the Infinity stones remember the ancient
one says that they control the flow of
time so if they serve a fundamental
function every time you're not using
them what's going to happen to the
universe is it gonna cause more problems
down the line that's an Avengers level
problem like Doctor Strange no longer
has the eye of Okimoto because he
doesn't have the time stone anymore
because Thanos destroyed it and it was
one of the few things he was using to
keep
mahmu at bay so there are consequences
to the end of Avengers endgame that they
have not dealt with yet or addressed
number eight will Tom Holland re sign a
new contract beyond spider-man three so
that he can be in Avengers five and will
Marvel Studios and so Neary signed their
sharing arrangement allowing more
spider-man in the MCU right now Marvel's
contract with Sony is up after
spider-man far from home but Tom Holland
still has one movie on his Spiderman
contract with Sony so they wanted to be
dicks about it Sony could turn around
and make spider-man 3 without Marvel and
go back to wait things used to be but
don't freak out yet because the good
news is based on what all the decision
makers and producers have said that
doesn't seem very likely but given VY he
did say that they wouldn't talk more
about that till after spider-man far
from home hit theaters so then they'll
start talking about the future of
spider-man in the Marvel Cinematic
Universe 7 what's the new official
roster going to be because you have a
whole bunch of new characters that we
just introduced a couple characters
either died or retired in the case of
Hawkeye like he's officially retired now
so if he comes back for other future
Avengers films it'll probably just be
small cameos but the newest members that
we just introduced that have not
officially or just officially joined the
Avengers are black panther spider-man
ant-man Falcon because he's Captain
America now maybe dr. strange and
sometimes Winter Soldier who's kind of a
contract player kind of like Captain
Marvel like she's mostly a space based
character that comes to help out when
she's needed but for the most part she
stays in outer space so you can't really
call those characters permanent Avengers
just like temporary sometimes Avengers
the new full roster of earth-based
heroes assuming people resigned
contracts and just don't come back are
Hulk Thor war machine Ant Man Spider Man
Black Panther Doctor Strange
vision and Scarlet Witch if they resign
contracts Winter Soldier in Falcon
Captain America wouldn't be surprised if
the wasp winds up joining the Avengers
at some point just because it seems like
they're headed in that direction ant-man
just joined so why wouldn't she also
then join the team later but we're still
at the beginning of Marvel phase 4 so
there's so many new characters to
introduce like vision and Scarlet Witch
didn't become part of the Avengers till
after Avengers age of Ultron so don't be
surprised if we get some new characters
that will become Avengers later during
phase 4
but just because people become Avengers
doesn't guarantee that they'll be in an
Avengers movie they always have to find
reasons for the super powerful
characters to be busy off doing other
stuff so at any given time there's only
six or seven characters on screen
regardless of how many characters in the
MCU consider themselves Avengers six
what's gonna happen with all the extra
stark tech and things that Ironman was
working on that we didn't see during
avengers endgame really good example of
that is the new spider-man suit
technology the special printer
technology on the back of his plane what
a surprise the Tony Stark has all this
advanced tech that he leaves behind for
people to use but never bothers to
explain until it's time for someone to
use it like oh by the way I have this
really cool toy feel free to play with
it when you need to a lot of times what
you see in stories though that they also
use that as opportunities for villains
number five who's going to fill the
power vacuum for better and for worse so
big running theme in Spider Man far from
home right now is who's gonna pick up
the legacy of Iron Man and become the
next Tony Stark who's gonna be that next
a list hero that everyone looks to who's
going to assume a leadership of the
Avengers if they used to follow Captain
America and Iron Man together labs all
set up boss Oh actually he's the boss
I just pay for everything and design
everything black widow kind of took the
mantle of leadership between infinity
war and Avengers end game let's you
stayed at the Avengers base permanently
just liaison with all the other heroes
around the globe trying to pick up the
pieces going into phase four just
knowing the characters that we have
right now best candidates for leaders
are Black Panther downside is he's a
king though and he doesn't have a lot of
free time but he is one of the biggest
figures of authority and he has all the
money in the world to fund the Avengers
with he's even richer than Tony Stark
because of vibranium then maybe there's
dr. strange too because he's such a
global authority on keeping the peace in
a supernatural extra dimensional sense
and he's one of the smartest Avengers -
he's smart like Tony Stark but he's also
one of the most powerful sorcerers in
the universe on the flip side of that
coin number four who is the next big
villain after Thanos when you do
Avengers movies it has to be an epic big
bad that no one hero by themselves can
defeat and you always have to be
building towards a much more big
ultimate threat every six to eight years
as they did with danos started with Loki
in the first Avengers movie then
they did Ultron slightly worst villain
then they reveal fan OHS the ultimate
big bat of the first 22 films there are
a lot of characters worse than tano's in
the MCU already you add the Fox x-men
Fantastic Four characters there's even
more dr. doom came the conquer the super
Skrulls The Secret Invasion Scrolls in
Norman Osborn Dark Avengers are all good
medium level Avengers villains people
who are powerful enough to threaten all
the Avengers together but aren't
necessarily big cosmic threats next big
overarching grand villains though you
have Dormammu Galactus in the Celestials
all solid picks even if you don't
consider some of the more obscure
villains from the Marvel Comics really
hoping someday though that they do
Galactus they fight him and then in a
later movie have to team up with him
against an even bigger problem but
that's years years down the road 3 will
they try to include x-men or Fantastic
Four characters in that next Avengers
movie the end of phase 4 is a very good
time to start setting those people up
like the Hitman Feige said it's gonna be
a couple years there'll be a cooling-off
period for those x-men characters before
you see them pop up Reed Richards would
be a badass addition to the Avengers one
of the few people that's capable of
saying they can pick up some of the
mantle of Tony Stark in terms of
brilliance you have to look at a lot of
the qualities that they brought to the
Avengers and Tony Stark brought a lot of
the money a lot of the authority and a
lot of the brains to the team Reed
Richards is even smarter than that so if
you introduce even bigger cosmic threats
you need someone on the level of Reed
Richards on the team too how will the
New Avengers spin-off TV show's help
build two Avengers 5 Kevin Feige said
that the story of those spin-off TV
shows like the Loki show the Falcon
Winter Soldier show they would influence
the MCU going forward so they'll be
relevant to what's happening by the time
we get to Avengers 5 but I think part of
the idea is is that they're serving
underserved characters because when you
do an Avengers film you only have so
much time to devote to character
development so the B and C less
characters the lesser people usually
don't get a lot of screen time that's
why they're bringing back Baron Zemo
during the Falcon Winter Soldier show so
they could always do masters of evil
there's just a lot of side stuff and
character development they can do like
if they wanted to set up a Thunderbolts
storyline with side villains in the MCU
so that in the future Avengers movie
they could do dark
dangers speaking of which number one
what are they gonna call the next Saga
films what story is it going to be based
on they call it the last 22 films phase
1 phase 2 phase 3 the infinity saga as
in the Infinity Gauntlet saga they
always based the movies on the bones of
a comic book arc there are a ton of huge
ones that they can do but I think a lot
of you will agree that the NICS saga
films the next 22 films should be based
on secret Wars the secret Wars saga
leading up to a giant multiverse
crossover as for smaller stories for
Avengers 5 there's always secret
invasion Dark Reign if they really are
doing Norman Osborn they talk about
someone taking up the mantle of Tony
Stark there are a lot of big Marvel
villains out there that could think that
they're up to the task of being the next
Tony Stark because no villain thinks of
themselves as a villain Norman Osborn is
the kind of self-centered person that
would think himself brilliant and grand
enough to be the Next Iron Man that
everyone looks up to Dark Avengers would
be an amazing story line if they could
work out to that it's a little too soon
to do Avengers vs. x-men but that's also
a solid pick for a later Avengers film
so let me know in the comments what is
your biggest questions about Avengers 5
and I'll add to a list of videos that
I'm working on I know there's a lot of
big questions about what's going on with
Marvel phase 4 don't worry a lot of
those questions will be answered in the
next couple of months I'll name a new
giveaway winner when I post new Marvel
but click here to learn about the future
of spider-man and venom crossing over in
the movies and click here for my brand
new Rick and Morty season 4 teaser
trailer thank you so much for watching
everybody stay awesome
I'll see
you